a fan favorite is being picked is the
leading actor for the new God of War
series but who is it and how does it
affect projects like our beloved
Stargate welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so last year Amazon announced that it
was going to make a television series
adaptation of the game God of War
this has been made in co-production with
Sony Pictures and penguin in a Parker
Hawk host me and Mark fergus's
television production company they are
currently working hard to get the
development for this TV series done just
right and actually penguin in the park
are going to be executive producer this
series similarly how they were for the
expanse but they're also going to be
writing this series but I'm going to
come back to that in a minute so we know
that they're in early development stages
of this TV series we also know thanks to
Catherine Pope who is actually the head
of Sony pictures that the development
work is going ahead very very nicely she
has actually said that she's really
proud of the work that's getting done
that they're working hard to expand the
universe and the worlds of the game
while keeping to the values of the game
but who should play the legendary Kratos
the main man the god of war himself Dave
Batista Drax from the Guardians of the
Galaxy was one of the big first names to
get thrown into the Hat the fans would
have gone crazy for that and let's be
honest he's kind of got the look
but there has been one actor whose name
has been very firmly the fan favorite
from day one
and this being a Stargate Channel he's
one of our favorites too
Christopher Judge
indeed
but why was Christopher just connected
to this project well he's already Kratos
he does actually voice the character for
the games he's actually voiced it twice
now in the 2018 God of War game and then
in the sequel Ragnarok he recently won
an award at the games awards given to
him by Al Pacino for God's sake
[Applause]
which must have been quite exciting and
it in fact was because he then went on
to have a speech for like what felt like
six weeks
um You Gotta Love Christopher George
when he gets excited after 10 years of
indeed he uh to actually see the real
Christopher JoJo smiles and giggling
excitable is just glorious but just
because he's our favorite and a fan
favorite doesn't necessarily mean he's
going to get the part well apparently
he's also Hawk host Beast favorite for
the role now Hawk hostby is one of the
guys that works with penguin and Parkers
I mentioned he's one of the guys that
wrote a lot of the scripts for the
expanse he works directly with Mark
Fergus who we're hoping is about to take
on the Stargate role now what I've
always been told is the penguin in a
park as a company is planning to expand
and they want to have two three maybe
four projects on the Go at once they
want the God of War they want Stargate
and Mark Fergus is actually going to
have his way and asked for that project
they want to be also be working on maybe
a couple of movies at any one time now
the way I've been told that they're
going to split this is that Mark Fergus
is actually going to take the lead on
potentially a Stargate franchise and
Hulk hostby will take the lead
eventually on the God of War I say
eventually because the God of War has
really been taking up all of their time
in the last six months they have been
desperately trying to get all of the
scripts done and agreed with Sony
Pictures and Amazon because of this
looming possible writer's strike that's
coming up if you don't know about this
right to strike it has happened before
and basically all of the organizations
that represent the writers TV writers
and moving writers in Hollywood have got
together and they've said you're not
treating our members very well and we're
going to go and strike unless you sort
it there is actually big meetings going
on at the moment representatives from
the main nine biggest Studios in
Hollywood started conversations with the
writer's Guild Etc from around the 20th
of March and we have a May 1st deadline
for there to be an agreement now it
looks like very tentatively that there
might be an agreement however that's not
what it's looked like for the last few
months and there is still big risks that
we might see a strike if we do all of
the writers will have to put down their
pens
so to get the God of War up and running
as quickly as possible Hawk Coast
beating Mark Fergus have been throwing
everything at getting those scripts done
now I'm being told those scripts are
virtually done and finally Mark Ferguson
might actually be able to go across to
Amazon and have a proper conversation
about Stargate but in the meantime Hawk
hostby is concentrating on a god of war
and they're starting to think about
casting
now the guy I speak to works at one of
the larger agencies in Hollywood and he
has been talked to me about that there
have been lots of names thrown around
for the Kratos character they really
desperately need the right person for
that part and really I'm being told that
that's going to be the first part that
they cast all of the other casting will
really flow from that for example we
need kratos's son now you need somebody
that's going to look like they're
actually the son of the main character
Dave Batista or Christopher Judge that's
going to mean a slightly different bit
of casting for the Sun so you start at
the top and you work your way down
and what I'm being told is the name
that's being bounced around the studios
quite a lot and apparently between a few
agents is that Christopher Judge is the
Studio's favorite but would Christopher
Judge agree
of course you'd agree he would jump over
this again go back and look at his
speech when he just picked up the thing
for doing the voice he was very excited
about it and to be honest after Decades
of working in Hollywood Christopher
Judge deserves this and as a Stargate
fan I would go absolutely nuts if he got
it
but how would him get in that major part
for a series that might run on for years
affect his ability to return as teal to
any new Stargate franchise
well there are a couple of rumors I've
got to bring you about Sony Pictures
Warner Brothers and Amazon and
conversations about the future Stargate
but we'll come back to that in another
video
I do have to mention though that penguin
in a Parker is the lead production
company for Stargate at the moment
unless something goes horribly wrong
they are going to be doing the
production work the development work a
lot of the scripts etc for the new
Stargate franchise so obviously if
you've got two big projects both being
bought by Amazon Stargate and God of War
both with the same production company in
penguin and Parker it's going to be
relatively easy for Christopher Judge to
bounce between the two if they want him
to now I have to say that it sounds like
all of the plans for Stargate at the
moment are revolving around that there'd
be a new cast but that some of the old
cast would drop in and out so
Christopher Judge as teal could turn up
for special episodes maybe even for
parts within any movies and to be honest
it would be incredibly easy for penguin
and Parker to arrange that I think about
the Mandalorian um The Last of Us
recently Pedro Pascal was banked in
between two major Studios he would have
to walk across the lot and film bits for
the Mandalorian then he'd have to walk
back and film bits for the last of us he
was able to do that thanks to the
cooperation between those two Studios
and the fact that actually the actual
place he was filming was in within like
100 meters of each other so this is more
than possible for projects like this
it's not a big deal for principal
photography and stuff and the work being
done in one studio and the actor
literally just to flip between the two
now obviously for Pedro Pascal that was
a little bit easy because he didn't
actually have to film big chunks of the
Mandalorian because the guy in the
helmet was somebody else a lot of the
time not all the time but a lot of the
time so that made things a little bit
easier but Christopher George will not
be having a major part in Stargate
neither will Amanda Tapping neither will
Michael Shanks these will be actors that
come in and out we are going to get a
largely Newcastle we're doing a lot of
the heavy lifting but what do I think
about Christopher Judge getting the
Kratos Kratos I don't know how you say
it main part well I just think he would
be an amazing fit the reason why his
voice in this part has been so popular
because he just embodies it now
unfortunately there will be some people
that will shout woke and they will shout
that oh wait a second Christopher Judge
is the black guy and Kratos is a white
guy and
but to be honest I don't care about that
sort of thing if the actor fits the part
I really couldn't care less this is a
fictional character and to be honest
most of the fans of the game the people
that actually love the God of War
already I don't think any of them will
have a pro problem with Christopher
Jones returning
so let's see how this works out I'm
hearing we should know something about
this within the next eight maybe 12
weeks and then we'll be getting lots of
other big announcements about the God of
War which will hopefully begin screening
sometime in the summer I'd love though
for you guys now to get in the comments
and tell me exactly what you think about
this project is Christopher Judge the
perfect man for the role or do you have
an idea for somebody else there's
actually a bit of a campaign for Hunter
Hearst Helmsley from the WWE to come
over and do it I'd be okay with that as
well I was a big Triple H fan when I was
a kid watching the wrestling so I'd be
okay with that as well but Christopher
Judge is number one for me
but get into the comments and tell me
what you think or who you think should
be playing this part
as always if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and you
can always join us over at patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where you could
see most of our news videos first and
without the adverts for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
thank you